So I sit on yesterday's bonus show that today
I was going to go through this new middle
East peace plan that has been released by
Donald [inaudible]
Trump and by Israeli prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu.
So let's do that.
But in order to do it, we have to establish
a few things.
First, number one, Donald Trump knows nothing
about the Israeli Palestinian conflict.
He's self congratulating by calling this the
deal of the century.
He thought Jared Cushner was going to achieve
middle Eastern peace.
It's a total joke at the get go and Trump
has completely in over his head.
Number two, this entire thing is absurd at
its face because you have impeached president
Donald Trump and indicted prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is saying, Hey, we figured out a
great plan with no Palestinian involvement
in actually figuring out this plan.
So that's ridiculous.
And the number three, this is very clearly
time to suppress coverage of both Donald Trump's
impeachment and Benjamin Netanyahu is indictment
respectively.
It's laughable at its face, but let's take
a little bit of a look at the parameters to
see if we by chance come across something
in this quote deal that makes sense.
Palestinian leaders have rejected the deal
on principle because it includes some annexations
of West bank land.
Now I've said before, I'm 100% against settlements
by Israel, which violate international law.
The settlements need to stop, they need to
stop now and in any realistic longterm peace
deal, and I'll lay out what that looks like
a little bit later.
There is going to be some West bank land on
which there are settlements likely swapped
for land of equivalent value, uh, from Israel
for a Palestinian state.
Arafat in the 90s said that it's potentially
okay if the land is equivalent, whatever that
means.
That's going to have to be debated, but this
nothing is going to happen if there cannot
be some land swaps.
The deal that Donald Trump and Benjamin Netanyahu
have put forth would include a four year freeze
on new settlement construction.
That's a start.
The problem with it is that does that mean
that an existing settlement cannot expand
or that simply there can be no new settlements
and that difference is actually a really significant
one.
It will also provide a path to Palestinians
for a contiguous territory for a future Palestinian
state when certain conditions of statehood
are met.
Now of course Palestinians are not going to
agree to the conditions that are outlined.
The contiguity of the state is an important
thing and from the maps that have been put
out, it looks like Gaza and the West bank
and a capital in East Jerusalem would be contiguous,
uh, based on, on roads that would be made
part of the state.
So in principle impeached Trump and indicted
Netanyahu establishing this without Palestinian
involvement is a joke.
Palestinian, uh, a Palestinian capital in
East Jerusalem is included in this, which
is good, but it's mentioned only as part of
East Jerusalem.
That's going to be a tough negotiating point
as well if there is ever a negotiation to
happen.
Um, and in total this is effectively a political
stunt.
That's all that this is.
And because this has come up and it's an opportunity
to do it.
Let me review my peace plan.
And as I said last time I did this years ago,
almost everyone is going to find something
they don't like about what I believe and eventual
plan would look like.
Every good compromise leaves everyone at least
a little bit upset.
That's why it's called compromise.
But this is the way I would see the most likely
path forward.
First of all, we have to talk about who's
in charge of negotiations.
Benjamin Netanyahu is not going to preside
over serious Israeli Palestinian peace.
It's just not going to happen.
He's shown that it is not in his interest.
It is not in his interests.
He benefits from more attention and uh, and
not having any kind of serious prospect for
peace.
So Benjamin Netanyahu cannot be the Israeli
prime minister.
If we are going to see serious opportunities
for peace, Hamas must be replaced by a more
secular Palestinian authority in Gaza right
away.
Hamas is not going to be a serious negotiator
of peace.
What would mock muda boss's role be?
They're currently in charge of the West bank.
I'm open to expanding the role of MOC.
Buddha boss Hamas does not want that.
Hamas has actually assassinated photog members
in recent years.
A boss, uh, has, has often, um, uh, given,
you know, lie riddled speeches at the United
nations, but to the extent that a boss might
be a productive partner, that's what I care
about.
I'm open to a boss being involved in the eventual
secular, ideally Palestinian authority that
would be in charge.
Law of return for Jews to Israel is going
to have to be maintained.
I don't see how you put a deal together without
it.
Um, the, the, the whole point of Israel is
Jews have been and continue to be discriminated
against and kicked out of so many parts of
the world.
Israel is a place Jews know they can go period.
And as long as that is maintained, um, I don't
know that I care too much about whether Israel
is called a Jewish state.
This is a point of contention that I am sort
of flexible on as long as the law of return
remains.
Uh, that, that is what I think is important.
The Palestinian law of return for Palestinians
to return to Israel is going to have to be
conceded to some degree.
And this is something that certainly governments
like the Netanyahu government have not wanted.
It can't be for 5 million Palestinians.
It's just not going to happen.
So again, I know that a lot of the reaction
to this will be, David, you're acting like
this wouldn't be fair or that wouldn't be
fair.
I'm trying to get to what is each side likely
going to have to concede to have a serious
opportunity and the Israel is not going to
concede return for 5 million Palestinians,
but some reasonable number that makes sense,
uh, should be included.
Once the blockade on Gaza is released, which
it should be, anyone who wants to move back
to Gaza or the West bank should be free to
do so.
And at that point it will be up to the Palestinian
authority to decide how many people will they
allow to move into Gaza and the West bank
and East Jerusalem.
Um, in the past a hood, Barack, for example,
suggested a symbolic number of Palestinian
returners and otherwise significant financial
reparations.
And I think that something like that would,
would likely be what has to happen.
Importantly, what are the borders, right?
This is a big point of contention.
I believe that the borders are going to have
to be more or less the proposed Clinton borders
from the 1990s.
And that's very similar to a lot of the recent
ideas that have been put forward.
The Palestinian territory will include the
West bank and Gaza and East Jerusalem.
Um, the problem is that the limits of East
Jerusalem are disputed.
That's when Donald Trump says part of East
Jerusalem.
This conflict is what he's getting at.
Let's imagine that there could be an agreement
as to what the lines of East Jerusalem would
be.
Jerusalem, um, uh, would Easter reus alum
at whatever agreed upon borders would be decided
there plus Gaza, the West bank.
And again, something linking them to make
it a contiguous state.
Uh, Jerusalem becoming the capital of Israel
for international purposes.
This is controversial, um, is in many Israelis
want this.
Certainly the Netanyahu government wants it
right now internationally, the Capitol is
Televiv internally.
Jerusalem is sort of the Capitol.
I'm fine with Jerusalem becoming the capital
of Israel for international purpose purposes,
uh, and Easter Russel and becoming the Palestinian
capital.
I think that there is going to have to be
some something figured out with regard to
the Jewish quarter of the old city in East
Jerusalem.
That's probably going to have to remain under
Israeli sovereignty.
We could do an entire show just about that.
But among the list of complex options, you
probably are going to have to negotiate.
Um, the Jewish quarter of remaining part of
Israel, there was desecration of the Jewish
quarter from 49 to 67.
You can read more about that if you care to,
but that would probably be, uh, something
that has to remain under Israeli control.
Of course, Israel has to immediately stop
all settlement building period.
Israel needs to agree in principle to remove
some settlements, they're going to have to
agree to remove some settlements to get a
deal done.
And then again, the larger settlements that
are not realistically speaking going to be,
uh, dismantled.
There will have to be land swaps and the land
swaps have to be of equivalent meaningful
land.
Not all the settlements at this point are
going to realistically be removed.
I wish it were different, but this is the
reality.
As Arafat said in the 90s, if they are meaningful
land swaps, it's conceivably something that
Palestinians could be open to the security
situation.
What happens with travel and checkpoints and
the Gaza blockade, the Palestinians will immediately,
and this, this is why Hamas is unlikely to
be a good negotiating partner.
Palestinians will have to stop all rocket
attacks immediately.
All tunnel building would have to stop immediately.
And existing tunnels meant to circumvent the
security.
A status quo would have to be destroyed right
away.
Um, there would have to be an agreement to
demilitarize Gaza as part of a peace agreement.
And in the two year period after the withdrawal
is real from Gaza.
Remember, but before the blockade was put
in, there were just thousands of rockets.
So there must be a demilitarization and ideally
Hamas would simply not be part of these negotiations.
As I, as much as I think Benjamin Netanyahu
will not be part of any credible negotiation.
I don't think Hamas will be either.
Israel has to remove the blockade and the
way that it would have to be done as conditional
Israel will remove the blockade immediately
and as long as there is a demilitarization
uh, in Gaza and no rocket launches is held
to the blockade removal would have to be held
to as well as part of the agreement.
And then a sort of broader key point.
All claims must be renounced.
In other words, both sides have to say as
part of this agreement we renounce claims
and this is the end of the conflict.
If in the future things are done that violate
that agreement, then they are violating an
international agreement rather than one of
these nonbinding things that negotiators may
put together.
There has to be a, this is the end of the
conflict.
We renounce all claims.
This is the agreement going forward.
Um, is this likely to happen anytime soon?
No, it is not.
And is it likely to happen under Donald Trump?
Definitely not.